so I'm gonna Craig Shapiro coming
leaping out onto stage also is JD
Richter Jeffrey Dean Morgan someone that
you may be excited to see an Academy
Award winner Halle Berry and creator
executive producer Mickey Fisher Mickey
come on out please sit Mickey sit next
to me do not be afraid
welcome to Comic Con 2015 you guys yeah
I want you to know how important it is
that they came out here for you because
Craig and Mickey literally had to pull
themselves away from talking to Shatner
backstage about his electric tricycle
that he was riding around on so let's
get into it first of all Howie you were
who's last time you were here for
comic-con I was here two years ago with
some x-men yeah I've heard of it yeah
I've heard of that movie but this is
you've been like what eight times to
comic-con yeah this is I think this
makes my 8th time my 8th time here yeah
I love coming here actually have you
seen have you seen the con changed since
you came from it with the original has
grown so much I don't remember the
actual first year I was here but it was
a huge event then but now it's just
grown like it's like tripled itself than
how it used to be and the more fans come
out the diehards the real reason that we
make movies are right here at this
comic-con event which is why it's always
my pleasure to come here excellence mr.
Morgan
do you read here with wanton I did come
here with Watchmen dong that was a good
one not as big as this so now now now if
you guys came back with watch yeah yeah
this big so can you tell people a little
bit about who your character is
what they can expect you know what
extant looks like in season two which I
know is kind of a departure from season
one yeah I mean a lot of the storylines
from season one obviously there is a
through line of the robotics of it all
and the fact that Molly woods comes back
from space pregnant and now it's kind of
the fallout of that and my character
comes in he meets Holly's character at a
crime scene I play a cop investigating a
murder and she's escaped a mental
institution
I think she's certifiable and you'll see
as the season progresses he continues to
believe this she's certified a man was
very delighted by that over there and
that's kind of where we kick off these
two meet at a crime scene and sparks are
flying kind of immediately and as they
try to kind of figure each other out and
what's happening to the world I think
it's great too but by the way just as a
side note if you accidentally get
pregnant you can just tell me like I
went to space I don't know I don't know
what happened I went to space and been
pregnant sorry I can't explain it
Craig what how's your role bit this year
and how have you made changes the show
and try to push the show in different
direction because the show is on CBS but
it doesn't I mean this I don't mean this
in a bad way it doesn't really look like
a CBS show like it looks it looks
different right well at every turn CBS
has said you know we pushed the envelope
push the envelope they've let us really
take the show to an edgy place it's sexy
it's kind of rock and roll right out of
the box with a mystery that is I think
you know people are gonna find really
interesting as it carries through the
whole season we we got a call the first
day saying you know do you want to come
work on the show
with Steven Spielberg show with Halle
Berry and we were like alright well I
don't care what it is we're in you know
kind of thing so and then we just turned
the show immediately to try to say how
can we heat it up how can we how can we
give it an energy say well how can we
dig into Molly's backstory her mythology
find more find more juice in that and
one of the ways was to bring in Jeffrey
Dean as a character JD Rick diner a man
that wanted to kiss her to put them
together and see where this what sparks
sparks that's [ __ ] so you mentioned
the name Steven Spielberg who's one of
the / overarching executives of the show
how has he been involved with the show
and you talk to them and then you just
ask him like a bunch of geeky questions
like how do you talk to Steven Spielberg
but then focus on your work you know all
I can say is this is where we get out a
little bit I can only say that because
it is Steven Spielberg we've gotten
email we have he's been shooting back to
back to back and so my goal before we
wrapped this season up completely is to
have that sit down with him face to face
it has not happened yet I did get to
meet Shatner backstage but I have yet to
meet Steven Spielberg that's the you go
Shatner and then Spielberg yeah you want
to go alphabetical we're working up yeah
yeah I can tell you that last season
when he came and we were shooting the
pilot we were shooting on Culver studios
on stage three and he came and you know
just to see like are the the props we
will put our director's chair
side-by-side and I was like running
around taking pictures of just our our
chairs together but he came in and he
was standing around talking to us I know
if you remember this but he goes oh yeah
this is the stage I shot et on oh yeah
we're looking up in the things of yeah I
shot here I think the space station was
like right over there and you could just
sort of feel the energy that's around us
really
just trying not to crap your pants so
you create your crater the show and
what's interesting about the show is
that it seems to mash up some subgenres
of sci-fi so there's a those robot
element and there's an alien element so
what was what when you first decided to
pitch the show how did you pitch the
show well I wrote the pilot on spec so I
wrote the you know the whole thing had
created before anybody ever saw it but
you know the pilot episode and and and I
followed the advice that they always
tell you as a writer which is to write
the thing that you would really want to
watch and and then I kept errantly the
show that I really wanted to watch was
about a an astronaut alien and when I
was also it was sort of a weird amalgam
of all these things I was watching at
the time I'm a huge Doctor Who fan as I
imagine I'm also a huge Friday Night
Lights fan the very first Nerdist
podcast I was snowstorm Christmas was a
Matt Smith podcast I just jumped in and
was it's a lot of things but I said
under rank this pilot and and what came
out was this show that was about aliens
and robots but at the heart of it it was
really about this complex complicated
fascinating woman and this family and so
that's that's sort of how it all ended
up blending together and how did you get
involved with projects like everyone
else who read that pilot I mean that was
one of the hottest pilots the year it
was sold I mean that made make a feature
this year a really rich man pilot for a
lot of money it was a hot property so I
like everybody else I read it and I fell
in love with the complicated character
with the idea of where it could go I
love the idea of dealing with a eyes and
extraterrestrials and the human species
and figuring out who will survive how
will we evolve I mean that's something
that I've often thought about and I know
we're all thinking about as we're in
this technological a age of all these
gadgets and things are advancing so
quickly I'm wondering how are we going
to evolve and our show really addresses
evolution and who will survive you know
and who will be the last people
and if we don't survive and if we don't
evolve we die and we discover that in
our show and that's just wildly exciting
to me to be a part of a show that's
about something that really isn't gonna
be affecting our lives
yeah truly I think if there were a
nuclear I think just the Kardashians
would survive you can't take them down
our new overlords welcome our new
Kardashian overload and we will toil
away in their underground sugar caves
you you also serve in names as executive
on the show so do you sort of see the
show as your baby in a way like you've
been involved since the beginning and
you and you how do you how do you
balance being an executive and being and
just and being an actor on the show that
has its challenges because some days I
just want to be an actress and that's
largely enough to remember my lines and
work with the other actors and you know
try to create this character but I do
also like the fact that I do have a say
you know I was an integral part of
hiring our new show runners you know Liz
and Craig we knew that we needed
somewhat of a reboot we needed a new
direction and I was lucky that I got to
be a part of deciding that I got to be a
part of bringing this talented sexy
older man thank you
you know and to be a part of you know
Kiersey Clemons she's also on our show a
young beautiful african-american actress
this just dope she's she's on the show
so I like having you know some creative
involvement you know not just being the
dancing bear I think that's in my future
having a bit
control yes and you enjoy the television
schedule well well I mean that that's
rough I mean I have two little kids so I
I spend a lot of time away from my kids
as a result and I'm what I've learned to
do is when I'm away I'm away and when
I'm home I'm really really with them and
that's been working for me but it's a
sacrifice show a one-hour drama you work
a lot of hours yeah yeah Jeff do you
feel the same way about the TV schedule
versus it's brutal maybe there's just do
you there's no other two ways about it
it's just a very hard thing to do and
for me I'm a little bit dyslexic in the
way that scripts come in generally at
the last minute we're getting changes
and it's very very hard so you work a
16-hour day and then you go home and try
to learn the following day's work for it
takes me a good three or four hours got
to get a grasp on some of the stuff
it's no joke but thankfully I'll see
Hallie in the morning and we kind of go
over the scenes and by the end of the
day we're going yeah it's a tough deal
you don't sleep for a good five and a
half months yeah I know it's really cuz
you don't know you probably how many
days you have to shoot an episode eight
days to shoot an episode and you
probably don't even know what day it is
most of the time though just on that
constant schedule yeah right I'll see
you this that you know in the last night
which was just last week we wrapped the
13th episode last week Callie had a sore
neck like a pinched neck it had her
backbone seized up it was four o'clock
in the morning after a 16-hour day we
writers in the crew look like living
hell she steps up on the set she has a
fight scene with a character I will not
tell you who that is but it's an amazing
fight scene to wrap up the season and
she looks completely dynamite and has
all her energy and she's just raring to
go
and when we wrapped that last shot I was
like you are a warrior you know because
she was in warrior mode for like 16
straight hours shooting this previous
moment and four seconds and it was super
super
how so I obviously recognize david
morrissey in there the governor yeah so
if you haven't been caught up on walking
dead he died don't spoil it does not
have to bend your viewing habits King
Joffrey's dead too all right
priorities yeah good night guys a lot of
media out there to catch up so how is
house eight Morrissey involves uh david
Morrissey he plays this character to buy
a shepherd who is the head of this new
organization called the Global Security
Commission last season we were in this
world the ISEA which is like a kind of
amalgam of public and private eyes space
exploration but at the end of the season
you know Molly woods destroyed the space
station they found up all these like
dangerous crazy spores out there so
obviously nobody's going back to space
for a while so we move out of that world
and then season two we go into this new
world the global security Commission
which is a little like the NSA of the
future Homeland Security that kind of
thing they're they're charged with
protecting against global threats
pandemics terrorism all that kind of
stuff and now they're they're charged
with solving this new problem something
that nobody ever accounted for this
great we were gonna time for a couple
questions so if there's the thing I
don't know where the microphone is but
if you have a cup of questions we can
take those but as people are lining up
right before we take a few questions
Holly why is this show important for
people to why do you want people to
watch the show what you know what does
it mean to you and just kind of tell us
about your excitement and what what
makes you happy about it Jeffrey please
Jeffrey would you please stop passing
notes
there's going to be a pop quiz if you
don't sit down and behave this is why it
was a 16-hour day like what you guys
gonna screw around if we just put out
you can ice enough to give us some nerds
and put out this gag reel and it seemed
like the camaraderie or the screwing
around was engineered it seems like in
the midst of this very traumatic show
you guys are actually like you like each
other and have fun which isn't always
the case when you don't like I mean we
become like a family like we have a
relationship like all the actors with
the directors with our show runners
we're in a relationship because we spend
17 16 18 14 13 hours a day together for
six months straight and so it's hard not
to have a relationship and when you
really like each other it just makes the
days go by and we Jeffery United from
day one we just we laugh so hard
we laugh so hard that I think the crew
gets pissed off cuz they're tired they
want to go home and we just get the
giggles and we can't fight it we just
have to you know they all know if you
just let them do it so that guy girl
that that you found that you put out is
just really showing the genuine fun and
the and the laughter and the lightness
that we do all have behind the scenes in
and we do have a good time
so so the question is ultimately before
with what why if people haven't seen the
show yet why is the show special to you
and why why why do you want them to
watch it and what do you want them to
get out of it
well I think this show like I said
earlier it's about something that could
potentially and will probably affect all
of us one day and that's our evolution
and what might that look like and I
think that's wildly interesting our show
this year got a real reboot it's still
about science fiction and about
extraterrestrials and AI but there
sex in it this year there's mystery
there's really cool characters there
beautiful people that come on our show
this year that it's just wildly
entertaining and while we're in this
world of science fiction these
characters are all being developed
little by little and you start to really
care about them and I think week after
week you'll want to tune back in to see
oh god what's gonna happen with that
couple oh [ __ ] look what they did
we have moments like that this year that
I hope the audiences will really enjoy
and we'll enjoy coming back to week
after week well yes you robots alien sex
I don't know why we're not watching it
right now I don't know why we're not
just watching it this minute
and I said earlier Jeffrey Dean we're
gonna night do swap fluids wait for it
you gotta wait for it but we do supposed
to be a mystery we have a question we
have a question hi what's your name hi
hey what's your question Alexis my
question is from Hallie and Jeffrey Dean
Morgan obviously you two are beautiful
and working together how do you feel
that's going to benefit season two and
your chemistry and everything cuz I
that's what got me don't want to watch
season two would I find ya right I have
no right that's what made me want to do
season two but first of all who are you
supposed to be all green and stuff poor
you so yeah we're really pretty parts
and you know you never know in advance
what it's gonna be like and you hope
that there's that kind of chemistry but
you keep your fingers crossed you really
never know and then we just saw the I
was on the set the first day and I was
like you know I think this is kind of
hot I'm wrong I'm standing here in this
thing we got to see the dailies all cut
together we saw the first episode I
realized we really I feel like we really
have something because they have this
chemistry that just fizzes on-screen
it's exploding off the screen it's very
cool and it's not always it doesn't
always work out this way it's kind of
exciting I'm glad that it's not creepy
to have a dude on the set going this is
kind of hot what are you doing we do
that again but slower yeah
I'm the showrunner I know what I'm doing
yeah thank you very much Alexis what is
your name hi there i'm pam pam i love
you guys my question is for Holly
you always play such wonderful strong
characters in your films what made you
decide to come to television well I felt
like you know the TV is the new frontier
the best writing is on television there
are great characters for women and women
like me my age group my ethnicity and I
felt like to really go do some quality
work which I was finding it may be hard
to do in the film world that I would go
to TV and be able to do what I love to
do and that's play great complicated
characters and I hope that I can have a
relationship between film and TV I
always have done filmed for television
never a television series and so I hope
that I can have a movie coming out in
the fall so I hope I can continue to do
both but for me television is where it's
at right now it's at the best things are
on TV Thank You Jaime sure what's your
question
I was wondering Mickey I already said
he's excited to see Doctor Who here so
what are the rest of you want to see it
come upon and are you gonna try and walk
the floor oh yeah great storm cosplay
there's no gay guy just look at all well
I like to try to find the storms I like
to go up to the storms and just
introduce myself I don't know I'm not
gonna be here long enough to see we
unfortunately I have to leave right
after this we just finished our show
literally and so I have some stuff that
I have to go do with my family and I
know Jeffrey does too so unfortunately
we're not gonna get to hang out much
after our appearance here we just came
to see you guys right now but if there's
any storms out there check this out
yeah where's the comedian do you know
what happens to a tow when it gets
struck by lightning
I do want me to show you or tell you yes
yes yes I really do what is your name
and what is your question
Jeffrey Dean Morgan I loved you on
supernatural
ESPN fans
yeah people hate that show
my question was what's your favorite
thing about your character John
Winchester
this character oh this character in this
show I'm sorry you threw me my favorite
thing about him is that Craig and Mickey
I think really made him a guy that I
think that you guys will all be able to
relate to I think my job JD's job sort
of coming into this season was to sort
of ask the questions that you as an
audience would ask but along with asking
those questions you also get a very
flawed guy who's in a failed marriage
who may be perhaps likes to drink a
little bit too much booze in the midst
of kind of his downward spiral that I
think he's in he's also ex-military and
kind of had a dishonorable discharge so
he has its problems with the system and
in the middle of this he finds Hallie
and and I think in finding Molly woods I
think he straightens himself out a
little bit anyway and so it's just nice
having a character that was a little bit
fleshed out that as the season goes
you're gonna find out more and more
about him and he's very funny you forgot
how funny you are he gets free writes
the best one-liners for him he's very
funny in life and on the show you're
gonna do great
so as we're going into season two Mickey
Craig Vicki why don't you feel this one
what should what should people be
expecting more of like you give us any
more hints or any more any more things
to take away sure I think you know I
think coming to the season two we just
wanted to come back at it infuse it with
a whole new energy new stories new
worlds new characters like you said a
bit of edginess darkness humor sets all
those things you know these people who
are locked in that in a red
the fight for survival all three of
these entities the aliens the AI humans
in the middle overall in this desperate
fight for survival and and we wanted hit
the ground running and the other thing I
would want to say too is that is that we
really wanted to make it accessible for
new viewers - we wanted people if you if
you likes using one you come back all
your favorite stuff will be there but if
you haven't seen the show we wanted
people to be able to just jump right in
and go for the ride so so we're
promising a lot of twists and turns a
lot of really fun stuff and and and and
asking the big questions like Hallie
said and and having a big heart in the
middle of all that - so excellent and
then last thing before we let you guys
go Hallie I just read an article on
deadlines with you where you said that
you would absolutely do a storm movie if
that was an option that is one of my
favorite characters that I've ever
played and I love with that x-men series
stands for what it's all about so
absolutely it's just fans have to tell
Fox that that's what they want to have
happen and then maybe they'll do it
starts here right here it starts right
now
fans tell Fox somebody tell somebody we
can do this we've strengthened dumpers
comic-con is a formidable army we can
take over anything do you understand
well then I have to have Jeffrey Dean
Morgan in it too so you have to say that
storm eats the comedian let's do it you
guys
I would like a huge round of applause
for Mickey Fisher Halle Berry Jeffrey
Dean Morgan Greg Shapiro x-man
now one day night to 10:00 p.m. on CBS
you